this is a uniqueness
and
i just fill you in matt yeah we were
talking right before you got here that
uh lou has been garnering some angry
are you kidding me with the
the backing up
this is the matt franco backup episode
this is a unique podcast in that you can
express
your your disdain
yeah people have been giving mean uh
comments sometimes about lou yeah like
in the comments can you believe that's
the only place to put a comment
i don't know where else
no they come in at night and write it on
the wall
[ __ ] you lou
[Laughter]
that's how many [ __ ] talks you
thought we were still talking bill burr
i didn't know no they loved bill burning
it up no but i thought you were talking
about his comments oh look here oh here
we go
please remove lou
used to be good and now i need to find a
new comedy pod look at that look at this
look at the emails
this is real fuck.com this is real
yes that's a question this is real no
absolutely i don't know if you
understand what they want to do here
matt but can you imagine the guy created
an account specifically i hate losing
to remove it's a petition to remove he's
looking for signatures yeah how many
signatures are on the i hate lou at
fuck.com was there a file was there a
file is there a file i don't see a file
this was submitted to us though
this is unbelievable what
this
no more show me another one
he loves it i just saved this one
specifically beautiful so hold
on no no don't don't
don't
yes no are you saying yes i'm saying i
don't want you to get hurt no
let me see no
he embraces it no let me see what
they're only words on a page what are
they gonna find and you have that saying
that's right
which is well he came in this morning
words on a page no we came in this
morning and we said the uh rick glassman
episode's doing well and he said were
there any comments that mentioned me
that mentioned my name if you watch the
rick glassman episode on youtube and you
go to the comments
most comments are just what the [ __ ] is
lou
[Laughter]
that's awesome i think rick
felt that during the show right so he
was they kind of expressed rick's
uh feelings on these comments no i think
they expressed their own no
rick was okay he said thank you for
having me on i'm going on his yeah i
know right now for you but it's it's not
like he invited me you couldn't find one
more comment on youtube put up the
youtube comments i need to like curate
all of them there's a there's a decent
amount hold on whoa well i don't know
just put up the first one that goes just
do it alphabet go to the comments
what oh
why
no there's so much tension in the room
right because i don't know
you don't agree with what looking at
these comments why oh oh what do we got
oh oh oh oh
oh go to the rick glassman one
oh rick glass here we go there's a good
one
uh
i'm calling i'm coming at 57 minutes i
may check back a few times well this is
this is bryce lk okay so he goes i'm
calling it at 57 minutes [ __ ] it
after an hour i tried i did not take it
i tried yes it's not five minutes it's
not i don't know how bryce was it has
been exactly 57 [ __ ] minutes this
bryce guy i mean he has no attention
span he doesn't have the ability by the
way this is the second comment he wrote
too he wrote another one also at the
beginning of it and you memorized
i tell her not to read the comments do
you read comments you're on social media
big time i i do see some comments yeah i
see comments i see reviews as well and
how do and how do you how does that
affect you
um more than i'd like it to
here look what trevor said trevor said
just a bit of constructive criticism
i'll be the judge of whether you're
being constructed right lou is great
thank you
it just didn't work in the episode with
rick
maybe you should have stopped the
sentence there's just too many cooks in
the kitchen i love that you gotta also
know during rick's episode we had uh
jackie's best friend natasha here giving
us an iv he had no problem with that
no a lot of people said whose idea was
it to put a live mic on the nurse who
only spoke for five minutes but you can
hear bags ripping the whole time
band-aid i like background noise this is
unlike any podcast i've ever seen well
yes is it it is it is yeah i love it you
know why because it's just me i'll tell
you what it is me and jackie were doing
prank calls and phone calls she was
locked in her house she's as neurotic as
i it
it's almost like keeping is one of
howie's pranks it's not a prank i enjoy
lou i enjoyed the awkwardness i enjoy
the funniness i enjoy the silence i
enjoy the laughs and if you don't like
it don't
don't watch yeah don't listen
i like it i have to say keep commenting
it gives i'm right there with you that's
all you know i love i love awkwardness
my uh my uh uh twitter handle is at
ludina look
great episode okay
lose a good guy thank you what coney
said coney yeah coney chambers i think
great episode lou is very good but
sometimes he's they're calling you a
podcast killer right halloween
wow wow they said the flow will be so
natural then he tells some weird joke
that that's it sorry for the guy seems
like a great friendship with howie
he resonated with that one yeah is that
the is this this is you two i thought
that was a description
it's captain obvious he's just stating
what's happening okay lou
try getting a word
let's see what nick said all right nick
it's two down nick the way things are
going this podcast is gonna be number
one in croatia before you can say
handbag
we have two sides of the coin i love
that we are one flip it over your head
no but the point is
we are we were and jeremy could tell me
we were 25th in croatia and now
we could go number one because you're
[ __ ] around
huh
lou doesn't talk into the mic he just
does everything else into it
says zach
i can tell if lou i can't this is what
chris said chris greer said kyle kyle
greer
no but chris told kyle directly
okay
it starts with
not even a ha
i can't tell if lou is the greatest is
the greatest comedic timing comedian
ever stop i can't tell if
that's what it says you got it out of
context
or if howie found him greeting at the
local walmart either way he makes me
laugh so hard
kyle
what a thank you
wait is that kyle from back there
and that means a lot kyle is the
demographic as a young
guy this is the demographic we got to go
for you know kyle said to me when i do
you don't get it don't take it
kyle when i did the uh uh i'm i'm
writing a movie a disney movie uh about
a sock that at one time had a hole in it
that darn sock
and kyle said to me after i did that on
your show he said
people just aren't going to get that
kyle said that yeah which kyle not that
kyle the other kind one of these kyle
how many cows are there there's two
kyles there
we have two kyles yes we have uh a lot
of alex's
and uh only one matt franco on the show
you got a pile of kyles sounds like you
got a pile of coils i don't pile my kyle
what if kyle had a pile oh
he'd have it for a while
[Laughter]
and then if the kyle write that put it
in the file
you if matt if you use the bathroom yeah
don't piss on the tile
[Laughter]
it's it's not a style
what
you know one time i walked a mile
and i pissed on the tile in style
and what did hitler want everybody to
say hello heil
we digress
all right anyway should i call tiana
back whatever if sure you dial
i'm gonna use the bathroom
[Music]
bye